movete movete choco roxana vallejos es
una de las únicas dos mujeres que hoy
dirigen en los 19 equipos de la primera
división femenina del fútbol argentino
me preparé tuve la oportunidad de
desarrollarme 23 años en afa en el
fútbol como jugadora y bueno actualmente
soy una de las técnicas más jóvenes que
hay dentro de femenino como casi única
mujer en este momento pero todavía en
sus condiciones no son las de sus padres
varones todavía estamos muy lejos de lo
que lo que es una primera división vamos
encaminadas estamos trabajando para eso
porque tenemos que estar a la altura
también es algo que también se ve en lo
futbolístico no tenemos el proceso de
formación que tiene un equipo del
masculino entonces estamos a años de
diferencia todavía en poder acortar esas
brechas que es lo que marca la
diferencia
en todo caso para las jugadoras es
importante que cada vez haya más mujeres
entrenadores es otra manera de tratarnos
me parece que es otro entendimiento
encima ya fue jugador así que también
nos nos entiende de ese lado tengo claro
que central también tiene en cuenta en
temas como el ciclo menstrual que por
ahí en otros plenos no me ha tocado que
es que se tengan en cuenta y eso sin
duda tiene la impronta de una mujer que
entienden nuestros nuestros procesos y
nuestro organismo
agustina quiere seguir los pasos de
roxana vallejos que puja por que las
oportunidades se abran para más mujeres
hay más de 150 entrenadoras que están
esperando su cupo y su oportunidad para
poder empezar a desarrollarse y eso está
bueno y ahí es donde nosotros estamos
trabajando para para demostrar que
realmente podemos y lo merecemos también
un gran objetivo para roxana vallejos
sería dirigir el seleccionador nacional
de fútbol femenino pero por ahora tiene
como técnico a un hombre